margie's with us in seattle hi margie
how are you
hi i'm good good how can i help
um we're on baby step two and
um my husband got served with his
summons for a bad debt
um and so after talking to some debt
relief
attorneys uh like four of them they
suggested
bankruptcy
okay and
we're about 33
34 000 in debt and credit cards and we
have like a
11 000 loan on our car
and about a hundred thousand dollars
worth of student loans combined
okay and and what's your household
income
um about 28 000 a year
okay who's not working me
why um
my daughter is at home
with it and everything and my anxiety
your daughter is how old seven
and are you being treated for your
anxiety yes
okay in what way um
therapy
[Music]
yes okay all right
well let me give you a couple of facts
that we can walk through
and then let's try to figure out how to
help you okay
okay fact number one student loans are
not bankruptable
okay yes again so after bankruptcy you
will still have a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
fact number two your household income is
twenty eight thousand dollars
are starving to death
and bankruptcy will not fix your income
problems
okay so after bankruptcy
we get rid of credit card debt and by
the way you don't have a car anymore or
you still have a car payment one of the
two
if you don't give up the car you still
got the eleven thousand dollars in car
so really when it gets down to it if
you're going to keep the car and
reaffirm it it's called in a chapter
seven bankruptcy
then you would have thirty three
thousand dollars in credit card that is
all your bankrupting
yes and who served you
um
the credit card was credit one bank
okay and how much do you owe them a
thousand
and six dollars okay
all right um
all right the third fact is that debt
relief attorneys
are generally not debt relief attorneys
generally what they are as bankruptcy
attorneys
and if you ask a bankruptcy attorney if
you're bankrupt that's like asking a dog
if it's hungry
yeah so the advice you were getting from
a
quote unquote professional was
self-serving advice on their part
so these are the things that are
disturbing me
in in you know so we're getting advice
from
people that are you know want you to
file bankruptcy because it's what they
do
you know they're a hammer so
everything's a nail um
if you're going to keep the car we're
not filing bankruptcy on very much and
really 1 000
is all that's triggering this and you
have a household income of 28
000 which is less than half the annual
income of the typical household in
america
and so i'm not shaming you i'm just
saying you guys have an income
issue i've been there myself one year in
my life i made six thousand dollars okay
so i know how it feels it ain't no fun
what's your husband do for a living
um he works at a car dealership
doing one reporter um driving cars
driving cars 40 hours a week
um well on average right now
33. yeah and how old are you guys
in our 40s okay all right
and so for me to help you have a good
life
a decade from now i want to be able to
paint a picture
that gets rid of not only the immediate
stress of this lawsuit
but also gets rid of a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt
and allows you all to have the freedom
can you imagine can you even
for a second wrap your brain around what
it would feel like in your home
if you guys made 60 000 a year and had
no debt
i can i envisioned it yeah that's where
i want you to go
and that's where my mind takes me on
answering your question when you
when i start gathering the pieces of
information up
but there's a lot of things that are
going to have to happen for
us to live that dream together okay
and i i am not a mental health
professional and i do know that anxiety
is real and i am not
uh qualified to tell you when and if you
can go back to work or what you could do
but i am qualified to tell you that your
family needs income
and i am qualified to tell you 33 hours
a week is not enough to work when your
family's just broke your husband needs
to get six
more jobs especially since the one he
has kind of sucks
is that me and mean no
but i mean it's a step up from where he
was before so that's good
then he needs to take let's take two
more steps up because
he's in his 40s and when he's in his 50s
i don't want him making 28 000
a year driving cars do you
no okay then we have to have to
intentionally take some steps
up from here and part of that's cleaning
off this debt
who's got these degrees with a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt
none of us what did you study
um i did accounting
um and i transferred schools so
my credits didn't transfer so i had to
start all over
and so that's kind of
made it difficult at one point and what
was the last job that you had
um
[Music]
administrative assistant okay have you
ever done accounting
in the vote as a vocation
yes okay what did you do
um as an administrative assistant i did
um partial accounting you helped them
keep the books
yeah yeah good okay because you do know
how to do it you just didn't finish with
the degree
yeah good good okay so there's a
possibility you start doing
accounting for some small businesses in
the area as you're
working for yourself and doing that from
home where you can keep your anxiety low
maybe yeah i've been looking for
work from home okay um is it the going
out thing that gives you anxiety what
gives you anxiety
um well a ton of things but um
as for me getting a job it's more of the
like
i'm afraid of letting them down
like not being able to show up okay i
understand
oh i see so if you had a uh
an anxiety attack in the morning and
weren't able to go to work then you'd
feel bad about letting them down and
probably get fired eventually for doing
that right yeah
yeah okay well that makes sense has that
happened before
um well it's happened where i haven't
been able to
um go out i know but it did you lost
your job as a result
no no my anxiety came after
after i stopped working oh after you
stopped working
yeah that's interesting
okay i don't know anything i mean dr
john deloney's not here to help me with
this so i'm kind of
trying to channel my inner dr d here but
the
um uh because i i know that what you're
facing is real i do know that and i'm
not questioning that but i'm trying to
figure out a way to get you guys some
income coming in
so i would prescribe no you're not
bankrupt just ignore this lawsuit
they're not going to do anything what
are they going to garnish your wages he
doesn't make any money
they're not going to do anything just
ignore them and move on i would no i
would not file bankruptcy i will put you
guys into ramsey plus for a year i'll
pay for it
let's put you into financial peace
university get you on a budget
uh but then you're all part of it is
you've got to do some stuff to get your
household income up or you're not going
to make it